The KV-1 and KV-2 are recognised as being
amongst the most heavily armoured tanks deployed
during WW2.
At least initially largely impervious to anything
less than a direct, point-blank hit from a
dedicated anti-tank weapon, the KV series
was so formidable that the first time the
Wehrmacht encountered them, Soviet soldiers
destroyed dozens of anti-tank guns by simply
driving towards them in a straight line and
running them over.
Introduced in 1939 and named for famed Soviet
officer Kliment Voroshilov- a man who once
personally tried to attack a German tank division
with a pistol- the KV series was designed
to replace the T-35 heavy tank, which was
somewhat mechanically unreliable and costly
to produce.
The extremely heavily armoured KV series was
first deployed during the Soviet Union’s
1939 war with the Finnish and then subsequently
used throughout WW2.
The KV series was effectively designed with
a single feature in mind- survivability.
Towards this end, it was equipped with exceptionally
thick armor.
While this thickness varied somewhat based
on model, for reference the KV-1 boasted armor
that was 90 millimeters thick (3.5 inches)
on the front and 70 millimeters (2.8 inches)
on the rear and sides.
Of course, there’s always a trade-off in
anything, and the thickness and weight of
the KV’s armor came at the expense of almost
everything else- the tank was slow, had limited
maneuverability and firepower relative to
what you’d expect from a tank this size,
and, to top it all, had exceptionally poor
visibility.
In fact, it’s noted that Soviet commanders
frequently complained about the tank, despite
the defensive protection it offered.
These sentiments weren’t echoed by the German
troops who initially encountered this moving
shield.
The KV-1 and KV-2 (the two most popular models
of the tank) were nearly invincible during
initial skirmishes with the Germans, as few
anti-tank weapons they possessed could punch
a hole through the armor, and even the ones
that could required uncomfortably close range
to do it.
As noted by an unspecified German solider
in a 1949 report compiled by the U.S. Army’s
Historical Division,
…there suddenly appeared for the first time
a battalion of heavy enemy tanks of previously
unknown type.
They overran the armored infantry regiment
and broke through into the artillery position.
The projectiles of all defense weapons (except
the 88-mm.
Flak) bounced off the thick enemy armor.
Our hundred tanks were unable to check the
twenty enemy dreadnaughts, and suffered losses.
Several Czech-built tanks (T 36’s) that
had bogged down in the grain fields because
of mechanical trouble were flattened by the
enemy monsters.
The same fate befell a 150-mm. medium howitzer
battery, which kept on firing until the last
minute.
Despite the fact that it scored direct hit
after direct hit from as close a range as
two hundred meters, its heavy shells were
unable to put even a single tank out of action…
In another account, a German soldier in the
1st Panzer Division noted,
The KV-1 and KV-2, which we first met here,
were really something!
Our companies opened fire at about 800 yards,
but [they] remained ineffective.
We moved closer and closer to the enemy, who
for his part continued to approach us unconcerned.
Very soon we were facing each other at 50
to 100 yards.
A fantastic exchange of fire took place without
any visible German success.
The Russian tanks continued to advance, and
all armour-piercing shells simply bounced
off them.
Thus we were presently faced with the alarming
situation of the Russian tanks driving through
the ranks of 1st Panzer Regiment towards our
own infantry and our hinterland.
Our Panzer Regiment therefore about turned
and rumbled back with the KV-1s and KV-2s
roughly in line with them.
The former report also notes that a lone KV
tank (the exact model isn’t clear) simply
parked in the middle of the road blocking
the main supply route and sat there soaking
up anti-tank rounds for several days.
“There were practically no means of eliminating
the monster.
It was impossible to bypass the tank because
of the swampy surrounding terrain.”
Among the initial armament brought against
the troublesome tank were four 50mm anti-tank
guns.
One by one the tank took them all out suffering
no meaningful damage itself.
Frustrated, the Germans commandeered a nearby
88mm anti-aircraft gun, positioning it a few
hundred feet behind the tank (basically pointblank
range for a gun design to rip planes in half).
While this weapon was capable of piercing
the tank’s armor at that range, before they
could fire, the KV turned the gun’s crew
into a pink smear.
Next up, the Germans decided to send an engineer
crew in under cover of darkness to try to
take it out up close and personal.
While they did manage to get to the KV and
attach demolition charges, it turned out they
underestimated the needed explosive power
and only a few pieces of the tank’s track
were destroyed, leaving the tank still fully
functional.
As for the tank crew themselves, they initially
received needed supplies to continue their
barrage on the Germans via cover of night.
However, ultimately the Germans were able
to cut off supply access to the tank and then
sent a whopping 50 of their own tanks in to
take it out, or that was seemingly their plan;
while the massive number of tanks were approaching
and occupying the attention of the KV crew
with their limited visibility, the Germans
were able to, according to the 1949 account
from the unnamed German soldier, “set up
and camouflage another 88-ram.
Flak to the rear of the tank, so that this
time it actually was able to fire.
Of the twelve direct hits scored… three
pierced the tank and destroyed it.”
Of course, all good things must come to an
end and the KV line’s many limitations saw
it quickly go from a near impervious mobile
fortress to a virtual sitting duck, with German
forces reacting to it by developing new explosive
anti-tank rounds fully capable of taking the
KV’s out.
While still used throughout the war, once
this happened, the KV’s were largely replaced
by the more well-rounded T-34 tank.
Still, it’s impossible to argue that the
KV didn’t make one hell of a first impression,
even if, ironically enough, it didn’t have
staying power.